mind your decisions I'm presto Walker in
a rectangle inscribe a semicircle along
one of its sides then inscribe a circle
that's tangent to both the semicircle
and the rectangle if the semi circle has
a radius equal to a and the circle has a
radius equal to B what is the value of a
divided by B I think Manoj and kept
Laiho for the suggestion pause if you'd
like to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
first recall that if two circles are
tangent their centers and the tangent
point are collinear this is because each
circles radius is perpendicular to the
tangent line
therefore ACB will be a straight line
segment this is true for both externally
and internally tangent circles now to
solve the problem connect the center of
the semicircle the tangent point and the
center of the inscribed circle notice
this will be a radius of this small
circle and we will also create a radius
of the small circle by creating the
tangent line to the other side of the
rectangle the bottom left corner is a
square if we extend the diagonal of the
square to the corner of the rectangle it
will also be collinear with the line we
just created therefore we've created an
isosceles right triangle where two legs
are equal to B and the hypotenuse is
equal to B times the square root of 2
the radius of the semicircle is equal to
a and therefore we have another
isosceles right triangle so its
hypotenuse will be equal to a times the
square root of 2 notice we also have a
radius of the semicircle right here well
now focus on just these triangles and in
particular we'll focus just on the
hypotenuse the entire hypotenuse has a
length equal to a time's the square root
of 2 it also has a length equal to the
sum of these individual lengths this
will be equal to a plus B plus B times
the square root of 2 we then subtract a
from both sides of the equation we then
factor on both sides we then divide both
sides by B and both sides by the square
root of 2 minus 1 we thus get that a
divided by B is equal to the square root
of 2 plus 1 all over the square root of
2 minus 1 which is approximately equal
to 5 point 8 2 8 and that's the answer
it's a cute little problem and I think
it's fun to solve thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]